35 seconds of logos sure and gladion
home is here to remind me of that
unpopular trilogy of movies that came
out more than ten years ago
Peter Jackson only teases dragon even
though he knows you bought the ticket
expecting to see dragon this is a lot of
exposition even for a Lord of the Rings
movie began as you might expect if he's
writing all the to Frodo why does he
need to do the whole it begin and a hole
in the ground crap
oh here Frodo what are you doing in this
movie not a thing this is the terrible
way to store bread this redheaded guy
he's instantly replaced by the subject
Aragorn jr. doors are invisible except
when a huge dragon wants to come in
Gandalf is facing all of his faith in
Bilbo one thinks that all kids do with
that age the dwarf spent as much time
training to fight dragons as they did
singing this trilogy would be over by
now are the dwarves supposed to have
blown out this candle that's still
smoking like three seconds ago before
leaving or does Peter Jackson not know
how candles work it takes 43 minutes for
this film's actual adventure to begin
and the first thing they do is go to
sleep until more boring door stories so
he's the Unabomber still a better death
scene than Miranda Tate's and Dark
Knight Rises even for a kids movie this
is pretty ridiculous no horses were
harmed in the making of the scenes that
have no horses these ropes aren't
remotely cyber-security
while the weed smoking sort of helps
explain this crazy wizard character I'm
not sure if it's a kids movie full of
snot infarct jokes just saying I'd like
to see them try on the one hand this guy
just smoked weed but on the other hand
he knows a lot more about rabbits than I
do so let him go
radagast immediately forgets his
objective is to lead the orcs away from
the dwarves and just goes in circle
[Music]
Bilbo's sword isn't glowing despite the
fact that there are tons of orcs around
man middle-earth simply did not believe
in handrails oh is this the same spot
where Frodo got stabbed in fellowship
are you really just cramming in every
single possible connection to the other
trilogy that you can its his excessive
consumption of mushrooms geez the guy
smokes weed and does shrooms I think
maybe all it takes to be a wizard in
middle-earth is a drug habit in a robe
is sörman supposed to already be evil
here is he just a dick yeah the song
seems to happen I start playing Final
Fantasy 7 but I end up playing Shadow of
the Colossus so the goblins built this
entire collapsible floor just in case
somebody came by and wanted to sleep
here for a while this fall would
definitely kill Bilbo if this movie
wasn't taking place in a physics free
zone man no one told radagast about this
place and didn't Elrond say that this
sword was of elvish make so the myosin
displays blowing near all these goblins
while gandalf sword Glamdring also made
by elves wings don't land on fingers
like this unless you're in middle-earth
where it happens in the first movie of
every trilogy you can totally tell where
the video game and the movie sort of
became 1t no physics allowed in
middle-earth we're supposed to care
about this perilous journey that isn't
remotely perilous for anyway this kill
is lucky but this kill is downright
inexcusable how does this blow not take
his face right off a minute ago azog
wanted thorn to himself then he changed
his mind in orders a henchman to do it
giving Bilbo just enough time to save
the day
Eagles again is that the only way
Tolkien knows how to resolve things this
rock looks like a bear what is this car
this is the single stupidest place the
Eagles could possibly have dropped off
the dwarves and now they have to make a
dangerous climb down a steep Rock wait
that's the Lonely Mountain well why
don't the Eagles just fly them all the
way there take them like 15 minutes I
mean seriously what do the Eagles have
to be doing right now that was
unimportant enough to stop doing it to
come rescue the dwarves but that they
couldn't also spend a few more minutes
to fly them all the way to their fucking
destination
[Music]
looks like def leppard is here for the
rock of ages' video shoot and although
per gallon see